[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Manuel Bompard bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous des citer des
Bouches-du-Rhône coordinateurs de la
France insoumise en est ensemble pendant
20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Julien Lécuyer de la
Voix du Nord bonjour Julien bonjour
Oriane bonjour monsieur bon parc bonjour
évidemment on va parler de la réforme
des retraites pour commencer l'examen du
taxi donc à chevet à l'Assemblée
nationale vendredi soir minuit comme
prévu avec seulement deux articles votés
pas et celui évidemment sur le report de
l'âge votre stratégie a suscité des
critiques au sein de la Nupe au sein
même du mouvement syndical est-ce que
vous dites ce matin que vous êtes trompé
de stratégie
notre objectif c'était de faire en sorte
que le report de l'âge de départ à la
retraite à 64 ans ne soit pas votée par
l'Assemblée nationale dans un délai
express de 10 jours puisque le
gouvernement avait choisi de comprimer
la discussion de ce point de vue là
c'est une réussite puisque aujourd'hui
le report de l'âge à 64 ans n'a pas été
voté par l'Assemblée nationale c'était
notre objectif et je considère qu'on a
réussi après il y a pu avoir des incomp
des gens qui ont peut-être pensé qu'il y
avait une possibilité de gagner à
l'Assemblée nationale d'empêcher
l'article 7 d'être adopté honnêtement
moi c'est pas du tout une analyse de la
situation dans laquelle je me retrouve
Mélenchon
depuis quand il y a qu'un seul article
dans ce projet de loi pourquoi il y
aurait qu'un seul article intéressant
l'article 1 il est important l'article 2
il est important mais la réforme quand
même attendez vous considérez que la
question des retraites minimum la
question des retraites minimum c'est pas
important j'ai pas dit ça j'ai dit en
revanche que l'article l'article qui
permettait de passer de 62 à 74 ans
c'est l'article 7 et qu'il n'a pas été
examiné au centre de la nuque vous avez
été les seuls à défendre ces gens de
seul outil de la France insoumise de
défendre ses stratégies de ne pas aller
au vote oui mais encore une fois
pourquoi on aurait dû accepter le délai
comprimé en nous en disant au bout de 10
jours on va arrêter les débats il y a
aucune obligation légale à le faire
c'est le gouvernement qui choisit un
véhicule législatif particulier ensuite
on nous dit vous allez retirer tous vos
amendements mais si on a déposé des
amendements c'est parce que on a des
propositions à faire et parce que le
gouvernement a choisi qu'on a vécu dix
jours pour débattre de ce texte de loi
parce que le gouvernement a choisi qu'on
a que 10 jours pour débattre de ce texte
de loi on doit rentrer dans le délai de
10 jours enlever tous nos amendements ne
pas discuter de l'article 8 ne pas
discuter de l'article 9 bah non pas du
tout de la France insoumise mais c'est
pas que ça fait débat c'est que bien
évidemment quand vous adaptez une
stratégie parlementaire chaque jour vous
vous voyez vous en rediscutez est-ce
qu'on avance dans cette direction est-ce
qu'on veut aller plus vite est-ce qu'on
veut aller moins vite ça c'est normal
donc tout ça a fait débat bien
évidemment mais il y avait une fracture
au sein de votre groupe on a parlé d'un
vote qui s'est joué à une voix après
mais ça c'est quand même assez
extraordinaire c'est à dire que quand on
vote pas on nous dit que c'est pas
démocratique et quand on va on nous dit
qu'on est divisé qu'il y a des fractures
donc là il va falloir se décider je sais
pas choisissez quoi je vous le dis
franchement donc heureusement notre
groupe parlementaire il est capable de
dire c'est plutôt c'est pas des votes
c'est plutôt des indications des
consultations est-ce qu'on va plutôt
danser direction dans telle direction et
à la fin une fois qu'il y a une décision
qui est prise on se retrouve tous
Gabriel Attal vous avez demandé de
rendre public ce vote pour savoir qui
était pour la stratégie qui était contre
parlementaire il fonctionne comme il a
envie et si Monsieur Attal vous rendre
des choses publiques je lui propose de
commencer à nous dire quelle est la
source par exemple des chiffres de 40000
bénéficiaires de la retraite à 1200
euros puisque monsieur du stop a sorti
ce chiffre il est incapable de nous
donner une source voilà ça ça serait
intéressant ça c'est important de le
rendre public par exemple le reste notre
groupe parlementaire il fonctionne comme
il veut et il a pris des décisions et
encore une fois notre objectif c'était
de faire en sorte que la retraite à 64
ans soit pas votée c'est pas le cas et
ça c'est une bonne chose parce que ça
permet maintenant à la mobilisation
sociale de se déployer vous êtes député
est-ce que c'est pas le rôle du
Parlement de se prononcer de voter mais
le Parlement il va se prononcer au bout
d'un moment mais la question c'était de
faire en sorte que le gouvernement
dispose pas d'un argument d'autorité
pour dire aux manifestants aux
manifestants au grévistes qui se
préparent à se mobiliser massivement le
7 mars prochain ça sert à rien de le
faire parce que l'Assemblée nationale a
déjà
en effet vous dites que vous d'une
certaine manière via cette stratégie
vous favorisez la mobilisation sociale
et ce qui est très étrange c'est que les
certains syndicats alors je parle
évidemment de Philippe Martinez ou bien
de Laurent Berger mais CFDT disent mais
non en fait vous nous servez pas ce qui
aurait pu nous servir c'est justement
que vous alliez au bout du vote et que
vous mettiez tous les députés face à
leur responsabilités donc il y a comme
une forme d'opposition vis-à-vis de la
stratégie de deux mouvements et donc qui
sont quand même qui représentent une
bonne partie de l'organisation syndicale
on a des appréciations différentes ça
arrive est-ce que vous ne est-ce que
vous ne participez pas une forme de
fracture sur le front de la mobilisation
sociale non mais attendez les
organisations syndicales elles sont
elles organisent la mobilisation
aujourd'hui elles appellent à des
journées de grève elles appellaient à
des gens manifestations elles sont très
attachées les organisations syndicales à
l'indépendance entre les syndicats et
les partis politiques nous l'ont dit à
plusieurs reprises
un moment quand nous nous avons pris un
certain nombre d'initiatives pour
manifester qu'on nous a dit non ça c'est
pas votre affaire donc par cohérence si
vous si vous voulez il faut aussi
entendre l'idée que les groupes
politiques qui sont souverains et ils
ont une capacité de décider bien
évidemment il discute avec les
organisations syndicales mais à la fin
ils prennent leur décision ils reproche
à la France insoumise de vouloir
s'appeler je pense que c'est pas on a
pas on n'a aucun intérêt à polémiquer
aujourd'hui on a eu des appréciations
tactiques différentes sur ce qui s'est
passé à l'Assemblée nationale c'est la
vie maintenant il y a la date du 7 mars
les organisations syndicales appellent à
mettre le pays à l'arrêt je reprends
leur terminologie nous nous les appuyons
et nous les soutenons et j'ai nullement
l'intention si vous voulez de rentrer
dans un jeu de ping-pong avec Philippe
Martinez ou qui que ce soit je pense que
c'est pas du tout utile pour la
mobilisation donc on a eu des
appréciations tactiques différentes
c'est comme ça ça arrive maintenant
de la nups et de l'alliance de la gauche
j'entends par là que le fait que les
partenaires
socialiste écologiste et communiste on
voulu retirer leurs amendements ils
représentent 50% de l'Alliance de gauche
au sein de l'Assemblée nationale et en
fait votre stratégie c'est imposée à eux
est-ce que ça dit pas quelque chose sur
l'avenir de la nupette c'est pas imposée
à eux les nos partenaires en fait
attendez nos partenaires ont fait le
choix de retirer leurs amendements leurs
amendements ont été retirés dans les a
pas empêché de le faire notre stratégie
mais c'est pas imposé pour arriver à
l'article 7 c'était leur volonté mais
c'était pas la note avec vos amendements
qu'est-ce que vous me reprochez de ne
pas être d'accord avec les autres bah
j'en suis désolé ça arrive mais on n'est
pas d'accord qu'est-ce que ça dit sur la
suite de la nups c'est ce que vous
pensez que snow a aucune conséquence ou
que finalement comme Sandrine Rousseau
l'écologie le souhaitait ça nécessite un
acte 2 ça nécessite de revoir à la
stratégie de réfléchir à quelque part la
première fois qu'on a des appréciations
tactiques différentes par exemple dans
la période précéd il nous est arrivé de
déposer des motions de censure seul sans
les autres groupes de la nups et la nups
en est pas morte pour autant pour le
reste si il y a une volonté des
écologistes d'avoir un acte 2 de la
nupette je m'en réjouis puisque à titre
personnel et au nom de l'organisation
que je représente la France insoumise il
y a une dizaine de jours on a écrit un
courrier à chacune des composantes de la
nups pour leur proposer discuter
ensemble une nouvelle étape on a parlé
de nouvelles étapes de la nups donc
nouvelle étape acte 2 bon discutons moi
je joue
une nuque plus claire plus démocratique
avec des votes transparents mais je
voudrais quand même rappeler que après
les élections législatives nous avons
fait nous la France insoumise une
proposition on a dit constituant un seul
groupe de la nups avec tous les députés
et puis au moins on prendra une décision
de groupe et cette décision de groupe
elle s'appliquera à tout le monde à
l'époque c'est les écologistes les
communistes les socialistes qui n'en
n'ont pas voulu donc à un moment là faut
être un petit peu cohérent maintenant le
fait de ça peut être une option mais
mais moi je ne sais pas ce que ça veut
dire si vous voulez de la nups mais je
suis prêt en discuter et je suis
intéressé à savoir qu'est-ce que ça peut
vouloir dire nous on nous avons fait un
certain nombre de propositions par
exemple nous avons proposé que la nups
ça soit pas seulement un accord à
l'Assemblée nationale ça soit aussi dans
le pays des assemblées par canton par
circonscription par commune ou quelqu'un
qui est encarté dans aucune des
composantes de la nupes puissent
s'engager participer aux actions bon ben
ça par exemple c'est une proposition qui
est sur la table on avait mis en place
pendant les élections législatives ce
qu'on avait appelé le Parlement de la
dupes qui était un objet dans lequel il
pouvait y avoir outre les représentants
politiques de la nups des personnalités
syndicales associatives des
personnalités du monde de l'art et de la
culture ce Parlement il a été mis à
l'arrêt parce que les autres composantes
nous ont dit pour l'instant c'est trop
tôt on est dans nos congrès alors
congrès sont passés discutons de la mise
en place de ce Parlement de la nupesse
moi j'y suis favorable je vous ai donné
ces deux exemples il y a plein d'autres
exemples discutons des prochaines
échéances électorales ensemble est-ce
qu'on peut préparer ensemble les
sénatoriales les européennes les
municipales moi je suis prêt à dire sous
bref échéance ou vous dites bon laissons
passer la réforme des retraites bah moi
personnellement enfin personnellement la
France insoumise on a écrit un courrier
il y a 15 jours et on est prêt à des
rencontres vous avez eu des réponses on
a eu quelques premières réponses on a
rencontré le parti génération notamment
qui a un des parties aussi fondateurs de
la nupes les autres pour l'instant nous
ont dit ah on est dans la la bataille
retraite donc on a besoin d'un peu plus
de temps mais je pense qu'on va pouvoir
se voir mais en tout cas voilà moi je
suis pas du tout style à l'idée qu'on
puisse travailler à une nouvelle étape
de la nuvette mais la question après
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on met derrière pour
toutes les élections c'est-à-dire pour
les sénatoriales vous souhaitez des
listes communes ou des candidats
communes puisqu'elle demande de scrutins
partout bah il faut être cohérent si on
pense que la nups c'est un outil utile
et je sais ce que je pense alors ce qui
existe à l'Assemblée nationale doit
pouvoir exister aux élections sénatales
en tout cas moi j'y suis favorable et
pour les européennes parce que les
écologistes sont clairement fermé la
porte bah je renonce pas les convaincre
j'ai vu que
il faut pas faire l'efforceurs donc je
ne voudrais surtout pas donner
l'impression de vouloir faire le forceur
de quoi que ce soit mais on a le droit
d'essayer de convaincre et moi il me
semble que aux élections européennes il
y a un des enjeux qui est de savoir
entre les trois blocs qui structurent la
vie politique aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on
laisse le rassemblement national et les
macronistes ont duel et nous on est
derrière parce qu'on est éparpillé
divisé ou est-ce qu'on essaye d'aller
contester la première place de gagner
les élections européennes ça doit être
ça notre objectif et si on veut gagner
c'est plus facile si on est rassemblé
donc moi je reste convaincu elle reste
favorable à l'idée qu'une liste de la
nupette ce serait la meilleure option et
vous pourriez vous ranger derrière une
tête de liste écologiste on en est pas
là mais en tout cas moi je pense que il
faut pouvoir discuter sans préalable
sans dire c'est comme ça
mais tout doit être tout doit pouvoir
être sur la table bon mais maintenant
pour l'instant j'ai bien observé je suis
pas naïf que c'était pas l'option qui
était privilégiée en tout cas par les
écologistes bah j'espère que peut-être
qu'il changera d'avis en tout cas c'est
ce que je souhaite si je reviens un
petit peu en arrière sur la sur la
stratégie le fait que le débat va se
décaler donc en
il vaut mieux mais cela dit c'est bon de
regarder aussi en arrière la façon dont
ça s'est passé
cette stratégie d'opposition et
d'obstruction via le via les amendements
est-ce que vous vous réclamez des
sénateurs de gauche qui adoptent la même
réclamer et moi la France insoumise n'a
pas de groupe au Sénat donc c'est
d'autres composantes de la nupette qui
sont représentés j'ai pas leur donner de
de consigne c'est pas moral non pas
continuer
mais clairement moi je le dis
franchement je m'en cache pas à mon
souhait c'est que comme à l'Assemblée
nationale au Sénat sénatrice et
sénateurs prennent tout le temps
nécessaire pour pointer pousser le
gouvernement dans ses retranchements on
a réussi dans la bataille parlementaire
à faire ressortir un certain nombre de
zones de floues de mensonges dans cette
réforme et puis qui prennent tout le
temps nécessaire pour ne pas se hâter à
voter à faire en sorte que le Sénat vote
la retraite à 64 ans
si vous voulez le sujet c'est pas je
veux pas que ceci soit examiné ou ça
c'est facile qu'est-ce que vous attendez
je leur dis surtout ne supprimez pas
enfin personnellement je pense qu'il ne
faut pas supprimer ces amendements pour
aller plus vite à l'article 7 je ne vois
pas pourquoi on accepterait de s'aborder
la moitié du débat parlementaire pour
faire plaisir à Monsieur Macron pour lui
donner une victoire au Sénat à quelques
jours de la mobilisation massive du 7
mars prochain je pense que ce serait une
erreur voilà ça c'est mon point de vue
après j'ai bien compris que n'étant pas
représenté au Sénat ils en feront ce
qu'ils en veulent mais en tout cas c'est
ce que je pense ce qui serait le plus
juste à faire dans la période actuelle
un dernier petit mot sur cet article 7
puisque il y a eu ce fameux tweet de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui a mis le feu aux
poudres jeudi à l'Assemblée et Gabrielle
attaque dit que c'est un message privé
qui vous était destiné qui a été rendu
public c'est vrai c'était ridicule si
Jean-Luc Mélenchon a des messages privés
à m'envoyer à moi je pense qu'il est
capable de il se concentrer il sait ce
que c'est qu'un tweet et un message
privé tout ça est absurde Jean-Luc
Mélenchon il a fait un tweet plusieurs
heures après notre groupe après la
décision de notre groupe dans les
commentaires il est venu appuyer la
décision de notre groupe parlementaire
assez risible je sais pas si Monsieur
Attal il discute avec Monsieur Macron
partout il t'interposé mais en ce qui me
concerne j'ai d'autres moyens je
l'informe il existe quelque chose qui
s'appelle le téléphone on peut s'appeler
pour discuter on peut y a des SMS qui
permet de s'envoyer des messages qui
sont pas sur la place publique parfois
on peut faire des visioconférences qui
permettent aussi d'échanger enfin je
sais pas j'ai un formulaire
tous les tous les moyens en effet à
votre disposition voire même les pigeons
voyageurs on a essayé de passer à autre
chose chez nous c'est connu
on parlait du compteur du compte à
rebours et vous parliez du compte à
rebours du 7 du 7 mars je reprends une
phrase que vous avez que vous avez
prononcé le compteur bourg est lancé
pour mettre la France à l'arrêt et tout
bloquer ça c'est le communiqué du
Conseil politique
qui dit ça bloquer le pays à partir du 7
mars c'est pour vous la solution
ultime c'est la dernière des
possibilités bah écoutez il y a eu dans
ce pays depuis maintenant plusieurs
semaines des manifestations qui sont des
manifestations historiques ça faisait 30
ans qu'on avait pas eu des
manifestations d'une telle importance en
France et vous avez un gouvernement qui
fait la sourde oreille capable de bouger
et qui n'écoutent pas qui continue à
dire c'est parce que vous avez mal
compris je vais mieux vous expliquer bon
donc à partir de ce moment-là vous
pouvez pas reprocher aux organisations
syndicales et aux manifestants de dire
si vous nous entendez pas quand on
manifeste y compris le samedi sans
mettre sans rentrer dans des mouvements
de grève reconductibles bah on va passer
à la vitesse supérieure donc moi bloquer
le pays c'est évidemment une formule qui
est qui est très qui est très radicale
c'est une solution encore une fois
ultime est-ce que vous n'avez pas peur
de rentrer dans un dans un jeu de
difficile avec les Français qui
pourraient être on va dire plus perturbé
par par les manifestations j'observe
d'abord que quand on interroge les
Français sur ce sujet il y en a 60% qui
pense que si c'est la seule solution
pour obtenir le retrait de cette réforme
c'est ce qu'il faut faire ça c'est avant
que le blocage se passe d'accord faudra
étudier en effet ce qui va se passer
après niveau ni moi nous sommes capables
de le dire par définition ça aurait lieu
après donc on verra à ce moment-là comme
il y a pas de devant autour de cette
table ce qu'on peut seul le seul truc
sur lequel on peut se prononcer sur ces
sur ce qui se passe maintenant pour le
reste encore une fois moi je souhaite
que s'il y a blocage ça dure le moins
longtemps possible mais ça c'est la
réponse elle m'a parlé au gouvernance
sans être devant vous pensez que ça va
prendre que ce blocage il risque de
durer longtemps il va devoir durer
longtemps moi je pense que plus il sera
fort les premiers jours et plus le
gouvernement n'aura pas d'autres choix
que de reculer et donc je pense qu'il
faut y aller un bon coup en quelque
sorte pour que Emmanuel Macron comprenne
que il est dans un bras de fer qui va
perdre voilà et après j'espère qu'il
sera raisonnable vous pensez encore qui
peut reculer hier il a dit qu'il fait
qu'il appelait au bon sens des Français
sur cette réforme bah justement moi
j'appelle à son bon sens à lui parce que
le bon des Français pour l'instant il
est assez clair vous avez 93% des actifs
sondages sur les actifs qui sont opposés
à cette réforme vous avez en fonction
des instituts de sondage autour de 70
parfois même 80% des Français qui sont
opposés à cette réforme donc à un moment
le bon sens puisque Emmanuel Macron
parle de bon sens et d'écouter quand on
est tout seul quand on a à peu près tous
les gens qui travaillent contre soi
quand on a l'ensemble des organisations
syndicales de salariés contre soi faut
écouter c'est pas grave de cette trompée
vaut mieux reculer pas mettre le pays en
difficulté donc moi je l'appelle à être
raisonnable pour l'instant il est pas
raisonnable Emmanuel Macron donc je
pense qu'il faut l'être voilà et et pour
répondre définitivement à votre question
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est la
seule solution pour obtenir le retrait
de ce texte de loi de bloquer le pays
maintenant je souhaite que ça dure que
les institutions les institutions
démocratiques ne sont plus suffisantes
manifestement vous avez aujourd'hui sur
la question des retraites dans nos
institutions que ce soit à l'Assemblée
nationale ou au Sénat des rapports de
force qui correspondent pas au rapport
de force qui existe dans la société donc
à partir de ce moment-là il y a
forcément un conflit entre deux
légitimités et je pense qu'il faut
entendre que la démocratie sociale ça
existe que le droit de manifester le
droit de grève ça existe et que c'est
pas parce que à l'Assemblée nationale ou
au Sénat pourrait y avoir une majorité
que un projet de loi est légitime c'est
pas comme ça que ça fonctionne c'est un
peu la fin de la démocratie
représentative
j'ai vu qu'on il fallait qu'on passe un
autre sujet mais je vous le dis
sincèrement ça a toujours existé la
démocratie la légitimité de la rue par
rapport à la légitimité de l'institution
c'est pas quelque chose de nouveau et
dire il faut aussi entendre la
mobilisation populaire quand elle est
opposée à une réforme c'est pas mettre
un terme à la démocratie représentative
mais la démocratie c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut adapter avec soin aussi et
quand il y a une opposition une
contestation très forte dans la rue il y
a pas de honte à à reculer ça c'est déjà
fait à plusieurs un petit commentaire
juste pour terminer sur ce de dossier du
de la réforme des retraites mais selon
un sondage ifope du Journal du Dimanche
vous l'avez lu comme moi 25% des
Français considèrent que le
rassemblement national pour ton très
discret pendant les débats sur les
retraites incarne le mieux l'opposition
à la réforme contre 23 % pour la nups
est-ce que c'est pas un échec pour la
gauche bah non parce que ce même sondage
si vous regardez quand on a une évalue
des sondages il faut regarder les
dynamiques or il dit que la France
insoumise je crois de mémoire dans ce
sondage et de quatre points en
progression par rapport à octobre
dernier sur sa capacité à incarner la
meilleure opposition à Emmanuel Macron
national donc puisqu'on regarde les
dynamiques je trouve que de ce point de
vue là c'est intéressant après il vous a
pas opposé que c'est Marine Le Pen qui
était au second tour de l'élection
présidentielle et pas Jean-Luc Mélenchon
donc forcément bien évidemment il
partait avec un peu d'avance dans la
bataille mais moi je trouve ça positif
quand on est en train de rattraper le
retard donc il faut en effet continuer
qui nous met en progression je vais pas
en progression mais vous restez derrière
malgré cette situation bah oui malgré on
est fait tout votre activité en effet on
regardera en effet au travail et en
effet on s'y fera demain je peux pas on
peut pas renverser la situation
politique en deux mois Marine Le Pen a
été le rassemblement national a été deux
fois au deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle pas nous donc forcément
on part avec un peu plus de de retard et
on rattrape notre retard et c'est ça
c'est positif d'avancer hier le journal
Le Parisien a fait sa Une sur la France
insoumise la France un parti trois
adhérents
c'est ridicule pourquoi c'est ridicule
la France insoumise c'est un mouvement
politique et on a fait le choix de
constituer ce qu'on appelait un
mouvement c'est-à-dire pas un parti
précisément et donc pas avec des cartes
d'addition on verse pas d'adhésion on a
pas de statut d'adhérence ça fonctionne
pas comme ça la France insoumise donc
c'est un mouvement politique dans lequel
il y a plus de 300 000 personnes qui
sont
à terre c'est comme ça qu'on dit sur la
plateforme numérique de la France
insoumise et ensuite la loi nous
contraints nous oblige à avoir une
structure administrative et une
association d'administrative c'est une
association et avec trois adhérents et
donc pour respecter la loi il y a une
sorte de d'association support au
mouvement politique mais bien évidemment
ça peut l'association
vous ne voulez pas d'adhérents puisque
c'est pas la forme d'organisation qu'on
a choisi
cette structure là elle est sous la
responsabilité politique des instances
dans ces doté la France insoumise donc
il y a pas de sujet en fait bon par
ailleurs je vous informe que c'est comme
ça depuis 2016 donc si nos collègues du
Parisien ont l'impression d'avoir trouvé
un scoop je les informe que ça fait 7
ans que c'est comme ça que c'est public
que ces déclaré en préfecture ça veut
dire que quelqu'un qui veut rentrer à
l'association il fait quoi il fait
comment mais non mais l'association
c'est une association support
quelqu'un qui veut rejoindre la France
insoumise et rejoint la France insoumise
il y a pas de sujet il y a pas un débat
il n'y a pas de problème
il va sur le site de la France insoumise
il indique ses coordonnées rejoint la
France insoumise il peut rejoindre un
groupe d'action pour habilités autour de
lui il peut participer à nos assemblées
représentatives qu'on lui une fois tous
les six mois et c'est pareil la question
du fonctionnement de votre mouvement
est-ce qu'il y a pas un problème de
démocratie interne est-ce que c'est pas
trop gazeux comme le dit certains chez
vous mais écoutez on a quand même le
droit de choisir une forme
d'organisation qui ne soit pas celle des
partis politiques traditionnels ça c'est
quand même autorisé donc il y a des gens
qui rejoignent le mouvement de la France
insoumise en étant attaché à cette idée
ils ne veulent pas être dans un parti
politique comme les autres et donc on a
été obligé à la fois d'avoir ce
mouvement ample sans adhésion sans
cotisation obligatoire il faut que ça
soit très simple de pouvoir le rejoindre
chacun peut faire un peu comme il a
envie il y a pas de groupe par
territoire délimité chacun peut
constituer son gros local
par vous par Jean-Luc Mélenchon et une
ligne plutôt portée par Clémentine
Autain par Alexis je crois pas que si
Corbières ni Clémentine automne et qui
que ce soit soit favorable à transformer
la France insoumise en un parti
politique en tout cas ils ont jamais un
fonctionnement moins gazeux ce sont les
mots enfin je sais pas ce que ça veut
dire en fonctionnement moins gazeux le
fonctionnement de la France insoumise
c'est un fonctionnement ouvert sous la
forme d'un mouvement politique et ça
restera comme ça parce que ça a été
constitué comme ça et que les gens qui
l'ont rejoint ils sont attachés à ça
c'est pas un mouvement sur lequel
Jean-Luc Mélenchon à la main mise
je sais pas ce que ça veut dire avoir la
main mise est-ce que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
exerce une forme d'autorité
intellectuelle morale oui pourquoi parce
que il a fait
22% des voix la dernière élection
présidentielle qu'il a été le meilleur
représentant possible pour le programme
que l'on défend et quand vous rejoignez
une formation politique vous le faites
plutôt avec l'objectif de faire 22 % que
1% vous voyez donc quand quelqu'un fait
22% et vous emmène dans des scores qui
sont des scores importants qui ont
jamais été atteints de manière
historique depuis des dizaines et des
dizaines d'années en France sur un
programme comme celui que l'on défend
ben vous plutôt tendance à lui faire
confiance sauf que la présidentielle est
passée à ce que maintenant il faut
tourner la page mélange et pourquoi vous
voudriez pourquoi vous voudriez que on
décide un an après l'élection
présidentielle de se couper de l'immense
mouvement populaire qui s'est déclenché
autour de la candidature de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon quel intérêt il y aurait-il de
notre point de vue à faire ça je veux
dire ça n'a pas de sens à part c'est
dans les commentaires médiatiques mais
sinon pas que dans les commentaires
médiatiques mais dans le sens où
certains déjà pensent en effet à 2027 et
c'est bien et c'est bien logique y
compris chez vous j'en veux pour preuve
une un entretien vidéo de de combiné du
député et les filles François Russon
pour ne pas nommer qui n'a pas exclu de
se présenter à la à la présidentielle
s'il était le mieux placé pour
représenter les plus invisibles de la
nation ça c'est comme ça qu'il le
formule mais il m'a dit qu'il fallait se
couper de Jean-Luc Mélenchon puisque
c'était ça votre question précédente non
mais dans le sens déjà à la
présidentielle et la façon d'une
certaine manière de tourner la page
Mélenchon pour aller vers les prochaines
candidat pour les filles vous répondre
je vais pas du tout mais mais mais je
veux juste vous dire c'est pas parce que
on imagine qui peut nous représenter à
la prochaine élection présidentielle
qu'on décide de couper le lien avec
Jean-Luc Mélenchon tout ça n'a pas de
sens et absurde Jean-Luc Mélenchon
lui-même a dit essayer de faire mieux
donc cette question une évidence que ça
soit Jean-Luc Mélenchon 2027 mais
lui-même l'a dit
donc je vois pas pourquoi
mais bien sûr et heureusement et c'est
bien c'est une bonne chose bon
maintenant votre question c'est mais
François Ruffin il a les qualités c'est
évident et c'est une bonne chose qu'on
est un certain nombre de figures
médiatique identifié qui puisse avoir
les qualités pour nos représenter à
l'échelle nationale mais honnêtement
vous entendrez qu'on est en 2023 que
l'élection présidentielle 2027 c'est
dans quatre ans je sais que la Cinquième
République est le pourri du
présidentialisme à outrance mais
peut-être qu'on n'est pas obligé de
rentrer non plus dans le piège quatre
ans avant et de commencer
le temps à Jean-Luc Mélenchon de revenir
mais non mais c'est pas
favorable à ce qu'il y ait une émulation
et qui a une figure qui soit le plus en
plus nombreux nombreuses et qui puisse
nous représenter nationalement c'est
mieux d'avoir l'embarras du choix
Emmanuel
De La Voix du Nord Julien en anglais en
Ukraine quel impact sur l'économie
régionale tout à fait grande question et
c'est vrai que on la pose plus et on
aura un supplément vendredi je le dis
tout de suite je fais ma petite auto
promo voilà merci beaucoup Julien les
clés merci merci